السنه
الماضيه استشهد
[Silence]
ب
السلام عل السلام ورحمه الله
[Silence]
سلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته السلام
ورحمه الله
وبركاته الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
لا اله
الا
الله اشهد ان
محم رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محم
مد رسول
الله حي على الصلاه
[Silence]
حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلا
حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
لا اله
الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه ونؤمن به ونتوكل عليه
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات
اعمالنا يهده الله فهو المهتد ومن يضلل
فلن تجد له وليا مرشدا واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان سيدنا
وحبيبنا وشفيعنا وقدوتنا سيدنا محمد صلى
الله عليه وعلى اله وسلم اللهم ربنا احينا
على سنته وامتنا على ملته واحشرنا في
زمرته وارزقنا اللهم زياره مدينته اللهم
امين اكم عباد الله بتقوى الله العظيم
ولزوم طاعته واحذركم ونفسي من مخالفه امره
ونهيه لقوله سبحانه وهو اصدق
القائلين
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق
تقاته ولا تموتن الا وانم
مسلمون اما بعد ماد ريسبكت ماد ريسبكت
‏all
all to
beeng with our par our famili
our رول الله صل
عل مذن جب رضي الله عنه
رسول
علس
together رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
معاذ رضي الله عنه يا معاذ والله اني
لاحبك يا معاذ
الله علس
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم لا تد في دبر صلاه ان تقول
اللهم اعني على ذرك وشكرك وحسن عت
الله and you in
the my and sister with you
the رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏time to be a thankful person a
person انكون شاكرا لله ع وجل
[Silence]
‏might be surprised
that the vision and mission and the
first الله سبحانه
وتالى قران الله سبحانه وتالى الاعراف
الله سبحانه وتعالى ثم لاتينهم منين
ايديهم ومن خلفهم وعن ايمانهم وعن شمائلهم
ولا تجد اكثرهم شاكرين
[Silence]
‏so actually did not say you not find of
pring
fasting doing this do that you will not
find the maor of them
gr so every الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى ‏thankful person person h subject
but i think it's a very important for
all of
us because see سانال سانال talks about
being grateful person or any grateful
person it's it's it's a major it's like
a fundamental between the human being
the servant and allah subh waal
الله سبحانه وتال ما يفعل الله بعذابكم ان
شكرتم وامنتم ان الله كان شاكرا
عليما الله سبحانه
وتال سبحانه وتال
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى
person before being
a
i know
there
may اللهانه
‏i can come to this
conclusion
that your
thankfulness to allah سبحانه
وتالى
us people
‏fa
nation relig belief regard of anything
el when we do something with each other
the first thing we say somebody mak
something good for you we say thank you
to that cor regard that
person now if we come to ourselves if we
just think we have our we have our we
have our heal we have our we a things
our da life
‏then if comes to your mind i would like
to the one me
all where
alling i would to be a thankful
person would to be a person i would
to praful
الله سبحانه
وتالى الله
سبحانه ما يفعل الله بعذابكم ان شكرتم
وامنتم الله سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله على محد صلى الله عليه
وسلم ‏teaches
us how to
appreciate what we have in our daily
life i'm going to give you a h
today as promised you will not find the
majority of them
grateful some tis i would every to
be grateful and thankful
person الله سبحانه وتالى many times in
قران
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم الله سبحانه وتالى رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم س او عائشه احسني نعم
احسني جوار نعم الله عز وجل او
عائشه الله سبحانه وتالى
عاشه خرجت من بيت قلما تعود اليه وعاشه
[Silence]
‏like
toate you have mys and my sisters and to
see the val of what you have i would
you to to imagine that thing just
close your eyes and imagine
your eas enough may may house may
god he
‏to eyes
and after that you are
going how you have in
life
second الله سبحانه
وتالى قران
واذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم سبحانه وتالى الله سبحانه وتال
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتال things thaty
can الله سبحانه وتالى
‏tr all over the you are
are i would
see
this things our life here in amica for
ourselves for our for for our
community gr
‏and here
you have for
gr gr
[Silence]
‏not cing
that you gr somebody dreaming
that not least what you gr somebody for
that
سبه the that he has given to
us i know i have that much time and to
how can i be a grateful
person by three things my brothers and
my sisters
first that to be a
person you have
الله سبحانه وتالى الله
سبحانه
النحل سبحانه
وتالى وما بكم نعمه فمن الله
الله سبحانه
وتال here i don't
ever سقم الله سبحانه
وتالى
نعم قال واسبغ عليكم نعمه ظهره وباطنا
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
‏people
الله
سهال there two ty
of that you can see and a l of you cann
see it's
unseen so the first point my brothers
and my sisters is to real whatever i
have in
my رول الله ى عليهم
الله
سبحانه to do for
us us
that because of
you because i
‏my
247 does every
likees
the that us
for this is
انما
على situation the second point how to be
a grateful thankful person to see that
to express
[Silence]
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم لو ان رجلا
من امتي اوتي الارض بحفرها ثم قال الحمد
لله كانت الحمد لله افضل مما اعطي رسول
صلل الله سبحانه
وتال الحد لدانه
‏here
واللام
الصلام كيف اشكرك وشكري بحاجه الى
شكر حث say how can i grateful thankful
to you
[Silence]
‏need
me ى الله علس حث ذ من قال حين يصبح اللهم
ما اصبح بي من نعمه او باحد من
وحك لا شيك لك فلك الحمد ولك الشكر ققد ا
شكر
يوم
this i have you me
any
come you
‏you andd mys and sister has to be a
thankful person is ex that by
your in this particular point sure
that
he
سجده
are الله
سبحانه
‏inck to
imm
you الله سبحانه
وتالى i would your
ears we do not we do not need
reason الله سبحانه وتالى
الحد have be thankful
and
you
nothing سهال
سبهالى عليه
الصلام there to be thankful for and to
finish my
[Silence]
اقول قول هذا واستغفر الله العظيم ولكم في
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام عليك
يا
all سبحانه
وتالى comm
‏just
سران does thankfulness the will be taken
away and in this
point
iare
that i
wasi and us when you see
aent i ask that
‏how do see
sit may how do see relation god sit
people unfor why
me why i sickness why why this why
that and that person i am very grateful
and thankful person
‏things
me and seen my
life seen
any
evenes nice car
house just
ands do that
‏i
me why now after happen to me i have to
say you know me i have no to say
that
and even as i second
[Silence]
‏body to sal because you are
charity you are ta in your body so
and we are recommended to do that so
there was a
person was admitted to the
hospital to do a surgery for his
الحد and the person the so much said you
know you
canay we can have some arrang for that
he said not cing for the inv i can do
that said
الله سبحانه
وتال now
forent see
how اللهم
اعلني غنيا
شاكرا ولا تجعلني فقيرا صابرا
‏a and person rather
being and pati because not every can de
that my and
sister after eating after drinking the
them to be gr
[Silence]
رول صل علسلم
الله سبحانه وتالى سبحانه وتالى اللهانه
وت الل اللهم ربنا تنا ذ الا غفرته ولا
هما الا فرجته ولا دينا الا قضيت ولا كرب
الا نفست ولا مريض
شا وت ولا مسافرا الا ر ولا مي الا رحمت
ولا حاجه لك فيها رض ونا فيها صلاحنا يا
رب العالمين يا الله اللهم ربنا لا ت هذا
الا بذنب مغفور وع مشكور وعمل صالح متقبل
مبرور برحمتك يا الله يا عزيز يا غفور
[Silence]
يا
الع for
man اللهم امين اللهم امين واقم الصلاه
انص الفحشاء والمذكر الله اكبر يعل
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان
لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمد رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله لا اله الا الله ربنا اجعلنا مقيم
الصلاه من ذريتنا ربنا تقبل دعاء الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين ولسليمان الريح هدوها شهر ورواحها
شهر واسلنا له عين القطر ومن الجن من يعمل
بين يديه باذن ربه ومن يزغ منهم عن امرنا
نذقه من عذاب
السعير يعملون له ما يشاء من محاريب
وتماثيل وجفان كالجواب وقدور
الراسيات
اعملوا ال داوود
شكرا
وقليل من عبادي
الشكور الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا ندي للصلاه
من يوم الجمعه فاسعوا الى ذكر الله وذروا
المبيع ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون فاذا قضيت الصلاه فانتشروا في
الارض وابتغوا من فضل
الله واذكروا الله كثيرا لعلكم
تفلحون واذا راوا تجاره او لهوا انفضوا
اليها وتركوك قائما
قل ما عند الله خير من اللهو ومن
التجاره والله خير
الرازقين
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله السلام علمه الله
وبكاته شاء الله
حث لا يش لاش
[Silence]
845 so pleas us for
those sch back
open a
18 be sch back if a register
come 10 take care
canes let us
[Silence]
‏one
ann us
[Silence]
الله واللام ومه الله وه
قي امين
[Silence]
‏s
‏ja
[Silence]
‏h
‏di
‏a
[Silence]
ا الله
‏s